and we're back game two
of the doubleheader the pirates and the
cincinnati reds from pittsburgh
pnc park the reds will be the home team
in the nightcap after winning game one
by a final score of 4-2
trevor bauer on the hill i know what
you're thinking what
did i miss the top of the first oh no
fred's will serve as the home team in
this one despite
here's brian reynolds and ripped to
right
brian reynolds first and second
moran had a couple of hits in the first
game
oh one pitch breaking ball grounded to
the right side
mustaches garcia on novato that's a
double play
that's it for the pirates in the first
for the pirates it's cody ponce
26 years of age listed at 6'5
255. ponce will go to work now against
the
right-handed hitter yeah
mcquirk castellanos after that
that's a good pitch curveball just maybe
a smidgen out of the strike zone down
suarez drove in one of the four runs in
game one
and now the 2-2 to suarez
in the air center field hit well to the
wall
goodbye suarez two-run job
and the reds out to a two-nothing lead
crazy gregory polanco
now the payoff pitch into the mid of
barnhart
first strikeout for bauer 202 batters
josh bell
the 3-2 fastball threw it right by him
back-to-back punch outs for bauer went
out batters shogo akiyama
as akiyama drives one into right center
field
that will one hop the wall jogo on his
way to second
and then they're standing with his
fourth double of the season
john ryan murphy's at 206 hitter
nasty filthy breaking ball third
strikeout for bauer
if you can hit the outside corner with
the regularity that he
normally possesses you're going to get
wild swings like that
joey motto leads off and
three strikes you're out at the old ball
game vado is gone one away and
castiano's coming up
ponce back to back punch out second time
he's gotten casteanos
so when he hits his spots and throws
where he wants to
get the same uh swings and misses nobody
on two men out
jesse winker will stand in him and a
foul tip struck him out
kept coming in the zone and cody ponce
strikes out the side
in the third two men are out colin moran
is still standing at first base and the
batter is
brian hayes off the middle
i tell you it's really something to see
to say this kid isn't overwhelmed is an
understatement
first and third two outs anthony offers
the hitter
look at this space hit for alford headed
toward the gap and alfred can fly
the ball kicks off of goodwin and this
is gonna tie the game and offers into
third
it's 2-2 well that ball was ripped and
it had to be to
get by and make sure he could score
hayes for first base goodman did a good
job of stopping it
from getting the defense but he didn't
catch it clean so it didn't matter
john ryan murphy struck out his first
time up
and oh walford thought about now he is
going to break for the plate he's going
to scar
wow that ball was not even outside the
dirt circle but barnhart
in a bit of a panic and bauer got there
a little late and now the pirates lead
3-2
the 2-0 pitch oh get up rip by
mustaches down the right field and you
can
kiss that one goodbye just like that
mustache
ties the game up well that is mustacha's
first home run in
some time reynolds one for two
infielded double play depth and
right to the second baseman that double
play
will produce a run and give the pirates
the lead
1-2 to polanco good night irene
six punch out for bauer two up two down
in the six for bauer
one two three six from bauer matt
davidson pinch hitting
and he struck him out nick turley
strikes out the pinch hitter well there
are two outs now
as richard rodriguez looks to earn the
save
doesn't look like we're going to need it
you won't have to worry about that
keep ryan hayes puts it away raise it
raise the jolly roger
and the pirates come back after falling
behind in the first inning two nothing
score three
in the fourth red's tied at the bottom
half
and the bucks win it